[Music]
we have terrific speakers today Nancy
babe from Microsoft Research right
around the corner
and right here it's pretty exciting
because I started in my home in 2012 and
I can't remember it was that fall or
spring but Nancy came in and presented
the beginning of this book the very
beginning and she didn't even realize
that this chapter was going to exist at
that point and now here we are at the
end the end so that's pretty exciting
and I mentioned her I was just going to
give a sort of brief plug for you to be
aware that as a research affiliate with
CMS she is available to you as a kind of
resource if you want to question if I
grew up researcher about your own
research interests she has served on
committees for our students writing
their theses before and is currently
exactly what's about to say she can tell
you whether that's a good idea or not
later after I've left the building
I didn't say interesting I said
entertainment okay I've been picking up
on some stressed out vibes unless the
graduate student body so I'll be happy
to hear that this is a talk full of a
lot of stories and not a lot of deep
theory so you can kind of just kick back
and listen to story out rock and roll is
it words yes okay
so we start my things I don't talk too
long
hi everybody so as Heather said this is
from what began many years ago in the
summer of 2010 as a summer project and
is now going to be out in two months as
a book I have stickers here do you want
a sticker pick one up on your way out
because I'm shameless and what I do in
this book it's called musicians art well
it's called playing to the crowd
musicians audiences and the intimate
work of connection what it's about is
the way that social media have changed
the relationship between artists and
audiences in a way that leads to an
expectation of more direct ongoing
interaction for example MTV did a study
some years ago of Millennials in which
they these were a couple of their key
takeaways that artists are expected to
be constantly accessible especially on
social media offering unique and
intimate moments to their fans and that
today there's an expectation for direct
interaction between fans and musicians
Millennials you can tell me if this is
true or not create intimate glimpses
into the mundane daily activities of
their favorite celebrities true or not
is margin is debatable but the fact that
there's this pressure out there to have
these kinds of relationships is very
real so that even people who don't want
them are feeling this pressure that
they're supposed to be and if they're
not being constantly accessible offering
intimate moments of their daily mundane
activities then they're somehow doing
having an audience in this day and age
wrong I don't actually think that
they're doing it wrong but that's a
pressure that's out there in the world
so why look at music if you don't care
about music I know some of you care
passionately about music and for some of
you music is perhaps background and you
wouldn't really think of it as an
interesting object of study there's a
great quote from the French polymath
Jacques Attali who wrote a great book
called noise and he gave a talk at
Harvard a few years ago called music as
a predictive social science and what he
meant by this is that you can look
throughout history and see music leading
trends of cultural change and
he goes through a ton of them but you
can go back a really long way and
whenever there's cultural change music
is one of the first sites in which you
see that change so music is a really
interesting lens for looking at music
which I would argue is inherently
incredibly interesting just to say
language is an incredibly inherently
interesting topic but it's also
interesting because it's it tells us
where we're going or where we might be
going so in this moment my argument is
that what music gives us the lens into
and this is I can all articulate this a
little bit more later is the trend
toward careers that at least seem to
depend on this kind of building a
mundane quasi intimate relationship with
your audience where maybe it feels a
little more like being friends than
being a star right now of course there's
plenty of artists who are operating
outside of this kind of model who are in
club scenes and know all their people
and whatnot but as a general rule if
you're trying to like sell records and
get on the radio and be covered in the
press and that kind of a career this is
sort of what musicians are facing and
what's been interesting to me as I've in
the last several years going around
talking about this stuff is how
frequently the feedback I get is well
you're not really talking about
musicians you're talking about teachers
you're not really talking about
musicians they're talking about
politicians and Lord knows that's been
borne out recently you're not really
talking about musicians you're talking
about religious leaders so pick any kind
of person who's trying to sort of manage
a market crowd people on whom their
professional identity somehow depends
and what you see in music we can see
there sometimes tweaked in different
ways but the same basic phenomenon so
and I want to emphasize that these
multiple modes of connection that I'm
talking about through which you're
supposed to be having these semi
intimate relations do include face to
face and I'm not drawing a there's
online versus offline or there's online
and offline these things are very very
interval VIN and I don't really think it
makes much sense to separate out digital
and material online offline they're part
and parcel of one another and it does
in this day and age it just doesn't even
make sense to me to think about
communication
that in no way has anything to do with
the internet ever in any capacity it's
so uncommon so one question I asked in
the book is well how did it get this way
you know it's kind of a weird thing to
say well if you'd like to have a career
as a musician what you need to do is
share your Monday share pictures of your
meals with people on a regular basis
right that seems like kind of a bizarre
piece of advice right and it is a
business I mean on the face of it it's
absurd why on earth would sharing
details of your mundane daily life make
people want to listen to the music you
make they're completely completely
completely different you know completely
different so there's a lot of answers to
this question as you can imagine and
they have long historical backdrops for
example the changing nature of work
which increasingly especially since the
1970s has required more and more
management of other people's feelings
and making people feel welcomed and
taken care of and a shift to a service
economy where managing others emotions
and managing your own emotions in the
service of other people's experiences
have become more and more part of work
it has to do with work becoming
increasingly precarious and so needing
to make sure that you're really well
networked and have really good
relationships with a lot of people so
that your next gig is always possible
even if your current one goes bad or you
may be freelance and gig laboring to
begin with in which case you might be
always in need of the next employer even
if you're quite content where you are at
that moment there's changes in intimacy
that don't have to do with work intimacy
used to be a very something that you
separated out from public at least in
the United States intimacy was the
refuge the domestic refuge from public
life and in public one kept private
matters private and clearly we're in an
era where that's we're sort of in the
opposite of that where private is meant
to be made public and
private is meant to be made public in
the service of something else now in
ways that it didn't used to be so it's
fry that is the intimate is made public
in order to sell stuff in order to make
customers happy in order to maintain a
market and so on so ships and intimacy
ships in public the hate expression of
of intimacy shifts in technology of
course massive massive shifts of
Technology and I'll talk through some of
those and music and in this in this
particular story music and music music
is something that doesn't really change
in a lot of ways all these other things
change around it but music is kind of
always there and always surged some
really fundamental human capacities like
the need for connection among others so
the piece of the story that I want to
focus on today I'll talk a bit about
music but the piece that I want to
really spend time went on is talking
about this period in the 1970s 80s 90s
and then into the 2000s but especially
those three decades where I want to
argue that the audience's set the terms
for how the internet was going to work
and that by the time people like
musicians and of course I'm generalizing
here showed up and said oh this is a way
we can market our wares and we can we
can interact directly with our audiences
and we can sell our products and we can
generate word-of-mouth advertising
through online communities the fans have
been doing that for a really long time
already so the artists were following
the fans rather than vice-versa I'm
gonna give you some examples of that
so let's talk about music for a minute
one thing that has kind of always amazed
me since I've gotten into doing this
work is I'll go to like a music industry
event and I'll say you know one of
music's basic functions is to express
ourselves spiritually and tonight
connect with our deities and the
audience will like give me a standing
ovation in that moment because I'm the
only person in the last three days who
hasn't been talking about money
like literally right it's so fundamental
in many people's who work in music and I
don't want to say that people who work
in music don't understand its deep
social value because they absolutely do
but when you're working in industry you
see it through an industry lens and and
the money is always there so one thing
that I tried to sort of figure out was
well when did that even happen that
music turned into a job that you do for
a living and you expect to be able to
get paid for making music because
certainly it wasn't that way 40,000
years before Christ when some people
somewhere in Germany carved out some
bones and made him into flutes right I
really doubt that somebody was like hey
I got a great startup I'm gonna be doing
bone flutes wanna invest right this is a
super amazing technology and you know
it's as old as the the drawings in the
caves we don't hear about it anywhere
near as much it if we're thinking about
the history of communication
technologies as in communication media
this is you know 40-some thousand years
old it has a fixed pitch so it actually
is a scale that's still in use in many
places in the world the finger halls are
beveled to fit fingers right
it had a mouthpiece that was affixed
with adhesive so you know pretty
advanced technology for for our humble
peoples so if we look at the history of
music
the long long long tens of thousands of
years history of music what you see is
that you don't find cultures that
have music you find people who aren't
into it but you don't find cultures
where there is no music right just as
you don't find cultures that have no
language at all and in every culture
where you find music if you look
sometimes now at its present but always
at its past what you find is that music
was something people did together within
their social groups and that doesn't
mean everybody could do the same thing
but it means that it was a community
ritual it might be pleasure but often it
was involved in worship in significantly
meaningful cultural social rituals with
one another
funerals births Pat life passages all of
those fun things that anthropologists
like to talk about and then at some
point we have we have people like you
know these guys are coming back from the
hunt maybe one of those guys was sort of
maybe they were employed by the Pharaoh
to be out shopping and I mean playing
music maybe we don't really know I tried
I haven't been able to find out but then
at some point it becomes very clear that
some people become musicians rather than
being members of the community who
happen to be holding the instrument and
playing it at that moment but it could
be you the next moment and so
musicologists often locate this in the
eleventh and twelfth centuries when
music notation gets invented in the West
there are other notation systems that
were invented in other parts of the
world in earlier times but musicologist
don't know that there's a non-western
world what's really important about
musical notation again a communication
medium that we don't often think of as a
communication medium is that it takes an
ephemeral experience that cannot be
captured that requires humans they're
performing it and it fixes it in a
permanent state that can not only be
transmitted so that it becomes so that
the song becomes separate from the
performance for the first time but it
also allows you to sign a name and take
credit as the person to whom that idea
belongs and it takes a few centuries
beyond for that to really
Shawn the idea that songs are things
that come from the minds of individuals
or the collective of groups rather than
things that God delivers or these are
the songs of my people or this is my
family's song so that idea of there's a
musician who writes a song is an
invention pretty late in the history of
music a few centuries later in the early
1600s you get ticket sales you get the
first the first moments where audiences
pay for access to see a musical
performance you had before that patrons
who kept musicians much as they would
keep gardeners or chefs and the
musicians would come up with sonatas to
be performed during the dinner or people
like Mozart were being commissioned you
know hey I'm throwing a party next week
I need I need a concerto can you come up
with something and I better like it or
you're fired but you're pleasing one
master and the guests were guests of
that patron once you get concerts and
ticket sales you're pleasing a public
who can choose as individuals or as
groups to buy or not to buy so there's a
little bit of shift there in the
relationship again we're now not only is
the musician separate but the musician
is a person at work performing for an
audience who is paying and very much at
leisure so a few centuries after that in
the mid 1800s we get to beautiful Jenny
Lind the Swedish songbird so Jenny Wynn
was a Swedish soprano and in the
mid-1800s she met up with PT Barnum the
founder of modern public relations and
publicity and he said oh do I see star
potential in you Barnum was famous if
you don't know for things like doing a
great museum exhibit with fines
everywhere that said this way to the
egress and everyone was like whoo what's
an egress and so they followed it and
the egress is that exit so everybody
left the building then oh I shouldn't
have to pay to get back in created a big
buzz so he decided Jenny Lind was he was
a market huh and he was very successful
so this is an etching of Jenny is here
she's waving goodbye to the adoring
crowds as she set sail from Liverpool to
New York City to perform in America and
she tours the United States for two
years there's reports of perfectly
dignified businessmen running through
the streets of Boston screaming about
Jenny Linds there was no escape Jenny
Lin mania was everywhere
and one of the things that Barnum did
and introduced to this idea of the
musician as celebrity was he monetized
it so you could buy Jenny Lind dolls you
can still get them on eBay you'll notice
they don't bear much resemblance to one
another let alone to her but you could
get Jenny Lind dolls
you could get Jenny Lind furniture if
you go to the store even today you can
buy Jenny Lind style furniture I have a
Jenny Lind bed it was the cheapest
antique bed you could buy because they
were so plentiful Jenny Lind beds
there's Jenny Lind diaper tables Jenny
Lynn you name it you could get Jenny
Lind every handkerchiefs I don't think
they had t-shirts so this is all before
recording technology you have this
beginning of the idea of the distant
celebrity that the throngs adore and you
buy stuff to manifest your excess
emotional attachment to to your
celebrity and then comes recording and
so with recording it's funny because
Thomas Edison always gets a credit for
the phonograph you know and you record
mary had a little lamb on his wax
cylinder and recording was born but
Edison said that he had no intention of
ever selling records based on the
personality of the person who recorded
who would care about that right mr.
Victor on the other hand saw the
potential here and one of the people
that he signed up was an Rico Caruso who
released hundreds literally hundreds of
albums in the early part of the 20th
century and a lot of things happened
this time right because if you think
about it
prior to this if you lived well let's
say if you lived in a town where you
were going to go see a movie
there would be a live orchestra that
performed the music that went with the
movie if you wanted to hear an opera and
you didn't have an opera house she went
to the next town or you put up with
whoever nearby had pretenses to sing
opera right suddenly you can go if
you're middle-class and you can afford a
phonograph and you can listen to one of
the best opera singers of all time in
your home whenever you want so on the
one hand for fans this is kind of
awesome right but on the other hand it
means that a lot of us this is a point a
lot of enemies ecologists have made it's
also the advent of people going oh well
I don't really know how to sing I'm not
really very good and the rest of us get
really ashamed of singing and
embarrassed to perform music publicly
because we have all of these models of
really really stellar performances and
we know that we're no Enrico Caruso so
we're just going to keep our mouth shut
and let him sing so you have the
invention of the amateur and the expert
you have the professionalization you
have the centralization where to produce
me and distribute and advertise and
market these things is very very capital
intensive so you instead of every town
having their own people suddenly there's
very few people in very large
metropolitan areas and it's getting
distributed outwards from there so you
have centralization experts amateurs
professionalization you also have
unionization of American musicians in
the late 1800s furthering the expert
amateur divide you start getting music
sold with photographs of the artists so
it might be Life magazine has a spread
of Caruso at home or it might be that
their picture is on the sheet music
right but you start using this oh you
might have feelings about this person
making the music to sell so by the time
we get to the era in which all of us
were born
it was kind of taken for granted that
there's people who are musicians there's
people who are audiences musicians
perform they do it on a stage we pay to
go see them do it they make a living
doing it it's super ritualized and the
performers get to talk and the rest of
us sit there and be quiet or maybe take
a picture right so we have this
naturalization of distance the
separation of roles between artists and
audiences this asymmetry of power where
the musicians are powerful and the
audiences are not and we have
discontinuity right you only encounter
these artists when they put out an album
or when they go on tour and for the
artists they only encounter their
audiences when they're performing and
otherwise or maybe they might get a
letter but there's long periods in
between whereas if you were the person
who was playing in the movie theatre
you'd be with your audience all the time
so what happens to music fans in these
centralized times the story that often
is told is this story of disempowerment
that poorer audiences became unable to
perform they were incapacitated by this
they lost access to the means of
production and then of course the mass
comm effects version of that is we all
became passive dupes and we're
inoculated into mass media ideologies
because we saw TV show one day and if we
think about traditions from the media
industries of measuring audiences they
thought about audiences at this time as
either a count of the whole or as
atomized
units right each of whom were a hatch
mark in that count of the whole rather
than say a community of people with
relationships to one another but of
course that's what audiences did right
think about those fans standing there
waiting for Jenny Linds boat to leave
it's not like they were all strangers to
one another who happened to magically
materialize on the dock at the same
moment what a coincidence
right they had word-of-mouth they knew
right they what are you gonna go see
Jenny I'm gonna go see Jenny there
you'll get to see Jenny
let's go does your sister want to come
yeah she wants to bring okay let's go
right and they were probably like
talking about Jenny the whole way and
did you see her do this and you just
needed that and I got doll Oh which one
you see all these things we think about
phantom now I can't believe they weren't
happening on those docks almost 200
years ago and it certainly persisted in
the time of mass media so this is fans
of a Norwegian band called turbo Negro
and a turbine aggro fans here tonight
okay they're very entertaining
so turbo negro fans are really really
really really into it as you can see
this is them during their annual
gathering in Hamburg Germany their base
the fans are based in Germany although
the band is based in Norway you can see
that they're dressed alike they're all
wearing the jacket that identifies them
as members of this fan club there's very
strict rules around this jacket it has
the local chapter name embroidered on
the back if you pay the extra $35
anybody can start a local chapter but
once there is a local chapter the local
chapter has to authorize the sale to you
not just anybody can get one and there's
super strict rules about you're not
allowed to wash it if you vomit on it
you're supposed to like maybe swim in a
river and if that doesn't work you're
allowed to use Febreze and they have a
nice link to the Febreze website from
their fan page in case you need to find
some you're never allowed to wear a
jacket from another chapter
but it's great if you get pins from
other chapters because that shows that
you're connected to the international
community so there's all kind that's
just a tiny subsection of all of the
things that bind this group together
they also have a lot of moral
commitments so their name is a fan group
I turbo Negra are a very very irreverent
band they have songs with names like hot
for Nietzsche and a lot of obscene
patently absurd obscene song titles so
they'll never get radio play
and the fans call themselves turbo
ujin's which is of course a riff on
Hitler Youth it's the turbo youth and
they're in Germany so one might think oh
that sounds a little fascist right and
their website goes into great detail
about wearing this jacket brings with it
a great responsibility to treat one
another properly we will not tolerate
any fascism in our group right so
there's lay out these really clear rules
of conduct for how you treat one another
and and don't think that just because
we're making Hitler jokes we're fascists
not the case so fans during this time
and we're talking pre-internet here
Turbo Union they're posted internet but
fan communities were pre internet fans
are doing all kinds of creative stuff
right there making fanzines they're
making videos television fans are making
music videos interestingly if you don't
know this fan videos television fandom
was an fan video making in particular
was a moment where women got to really
get into fandom and rest it away from
all those techie science fiction guys
and and Sherlock Holmes fans who were
kind of hogging all the good fandoms and
girls got to be like hey I'm making a
video and they were really good at it so
there you go this was the famous first
ones Leonard Nimoy doing both sides now
and fans did a lot of tape trading I was
very into REM at earlier stage of my
life I still have a very soft spot for
them this was an example of a fan
exchanged tape and what I put it up here
to show is not just that fans were
exchanging tapes and collating materials
but that we were going to great lengths
to you know make them aesthetically
interesting this is the tape trading
list that I would send out to people so
there were networks tape trading
networks and you would get the name of
somebody who had shows that you didn't
and you would send them your list and
they would send you back their list and
then you would exchange cassettes and
they would send you recordings with that
music on them so I built up a pretty
awesome collection and I was really very
popular with all my friends because I
had
and I listen to it a lot you know
there's nothing for a true fan like
having 18 versions of the same song
performed live each where they sing that
one part just a tiny bit different of
course these tape trading networks
didn't come out of nowhere they weren't
totally they were very fan driven but
they were also always not always but
there were often musicians who were
nurturing it right and the Grateful Dead
are really critical to this story in
many ways because of course the Grateful
Dead were very strategic in encouraging
taping of their shows and encouraging
fans to trade and they also did this
very clever early thing which is they
set up their own ticketing agency which
meant that if you wanted to buy tickets
to a Grateful Dead show you did it
through them and that meant that if
somebody was buying tickets to five
shows they could put him next to the
other people who were buying tickets for
those same five shows so they were
strategically seating people together to
form community and encouraging them to
trade tapes amongst themselves very
visionary in that regard and will return
to the dead in a minute because they
become important in ways that I did not
anticipate so what's really important
about all of this fandom by the time the
Internet comes along is that they've got
all kind of rituals for interactions
they've all got all kinds of hierarchies
worked out for what makes a good fan
what makes a bad fan what makes a famous
fan what makes a really well-placed fan
they've got all kinds of structures like
tape trees that they've built to engage
one another and they have an expectation
that fans are there they can go to the
fans and the fans the fans will be
around and they know to use media they
know how to use media to produce their
own materials all that has happened
before the internet comes along so if we
stop for a minute we say okay well
suppose I'm going to pick up the paper
and I'm gonna read about who were the
really brilliant musicians who got into
this early and figured it all out
figured out the internet early uh one
person that you often hear about is
David Bowie with his bow in it and
indeed Bowie net was really awesome I
mean among other things Bowie not does
have the
Directive remix project this is 1998
right so you could actually Bowie was an
ISP you could have a Bowie net account
and you could access your internet
through Bowie net and also through your
subscription get all kinds of great
Bowie products delivered right to you
and you could play with Bowie stuff so
he was honoring the creativity of
audiences another really famous early
innovator Prince gets a lot of credit
and Prince I will say that Prince was
also in the early 80s he was actually
dialing into bulletin boards where
people were talking about himself he
actually was getting in there with the
fans really really early in in the fan
spaces this is 97 98 he releases his
album crystal ball the four CD set tooth
CD if you order early enough available
exclusively on the internet hours of
unreleased music from one of the most
prolific songwriters of all time 30-plus
purple jams from Prince and a
collectible seized through seed the
see-through CD case that stands on its
own from fat funk to beautiful ballads
it's all here and it's all good all
right place your order here or by
calling 1-800 new funk which tells you
something tell a friend to tell a friend
to tell a friend right the fact that
he's got the phone number in there tells
you something about the internet of that
era one of my very favorite early
innovation examples of all time is the
Rolling Stones broadcast a concert live
on the internet in 1994 for 20 minutes
so they're really clever they're using
the embo they're really modern what they
didn't realize about the mbone is that
once you've opened an M Bone channel
anybody can use that M Boehm channel and
there was a band who worked at Xerox
PARC you can see where this is going
right so as they say here who was the
first live band in cyberspace in a
well-publicized broadcast to promote
their pay-per-view broadcast the Rolling
Stones broadcast 20 then it's whoops
sorry from a performance at the Cotton
Bowl becoming the first major rock band
to do so on that network of millions of
computers but their moment in the
limelight was tarnished by a
little-known band called severe tire
damage knowing that the channel
the stones was open to anyone and
wanting to take advantage of the
worldwide audience the stones would
attract the group broadcast an impromptu
performance from the Xerox PARC offices
in Palo Alto direct Palo Alto directly
before and after the Stones concert I
think this is the great truly great
example of computer geeks disrupting the
music industry it was actually the
parking garage I'm told and it's also an
example of how from the very beginning
when musicians showed up and we're like
okay we're gonna use this new medium
other people were like oh we know how to
do it better
and actually we're setting the rules
here so what actually happened was not
that people like Prince and the Rolling
Stones and David Bowie were the leaders
of the internet the audience was the
leaders of the internet and they did
this through all kinds of things as
computed as networked computing emerged
they did it through community computing
I'll talk a good example they did it
through research labs mailing lists
bulletin boards using that news groups
fan websites blogs archives on and on
and on and on all before MySpace or
Facebook or any of those things came
into existence so this is sometimes
you're doing historical research and you
just are like wow I couldn't have
written a better thing I'm not even
gonna get away with this this is too
good so this is from 1973 in Sanford
Aaron in the Bay Area and it's it's a
project called community memory and what
they did was they created these computer
terminals and they left them in public
places in the Bay Area and people could
go and they could leave notes on the
bulletin boards and they could read the
notes on the bulletin boards and there
would be sort of printouts of what had
come up through recently for people who
didn't want to actually use the machine
they could just flip through the stuff
um
the very first one the very first
community memory machine was installed
at Leopold's records store in Berkeley
California right so they put the music
the record store at the center of that
community that they were seeking to
remember
also in the early 70s at the University
of Illinois there was a project called
Plato that developed these lovely little
machines which were sent around the
United States to other places that we're
developing that were computing I had
played or I grew up in Champaign Urbana
Illinois and we had Plato terminals in
my classroom in fourth fifth and sixth
grade and I remember staying after
school and talking to people in Texas
from Illinois in like 1974 who knew I
would become an Internet researcher so
there were a lot of discussion forums
that were available on Plato and of
course one of them was to discuss music
it was not the only one but again from
this very early beginning music is there
you wouldn't build a computer system
that didn't have music and then we had
Stanford in the Bay Area the Stanford
artificial intelligence lab which was
established in around around 1970s today
among the many geniuses they employed
were of course some dead heads it was
San Francisco it was 1970 you had to be
a Deadhead or they kicked you out so at
a time when computing looked like this
in the lab there were people who were
sitting there and using these machines
to digitize all the Grateful Dead lyrics
and of course they eventually run into
John Perry Barlow Grateful Dead lyricist
among other attributes and they hand him
this stack of look we digitized all your
lyrics and he's like oh maybe there's
something to these computers huh this is
very interesting right and of course he
goes on to become one of the founding
figures in the history of the internet
co-creator of the Electronic Frontier
Foundation and many many many other
things in addition to writing songs for
the Grateful Dead so you had mailing
list you had Grateful Dead fan mailing
lists and a lot often internal to these
labs or campuses you had used that news
groups this is a visualization of the
wreck
music hierarchy of Usenet and you can
see that fish tickets was a very popular
topic
this was the REM discussion so that was
pretty big filk the fandom things
they're not quite as popular Springsteen
was super popular kiss had a lot of
discussion going on and of course the
dead
so there's let me tell you one other
story about this with REM here which is
that so
there was an REM mailing list and before
there was an REM mailing list and had a
lot of people on it and then it got a
little too big and a little too unwieldy
and it stopped feeling intimate so they
said let's become a Usenet newsgroup so
they got a new they created a news group
this one and then what happened was that
all of a sudden all anybody wanted to
talk about it was all people who didn't
know anything about REM and had never
been involved with the group dropping by
going it's Michael Stipe gay and they
would say this is not an appropriate
topic to discuss in this forum please do
not raise this topic again and after
about you know 80 or 90 repetitions of
that interaction the people who had been
on that original list like let's create
a secret mailing list and they went back
and created a secret mailing list which
never did as well as the original levels
meanwhile in San Francisco we bulletin
boards continue to develop the most
famous of which was known as the well
one of the most popular personalities on
the well was our friend John Perry
Barlow and when we think about the well
if what we think about it at all we tend
to think about it as sort of this birth
of Bay Area cyberculture connections to
the Whole Earth Catalog to that whole
kind of movement that Fred Turner has
written about so well there's another
story to be told about the well and if
you look in rheingold's book you find it
which is that the deadheads didn't have
a place and so they found the well and
for many for quite a while they were the
single largest source of income so
basically the
heads were subsidizing all of that cool
subculture so that they had a place to
be dead heads between gigs and as he
says those dead heads who did leave the
dead head discussion forum ended up
having a strong influence at the well at
large but very different kinds of
communities began to grow in other parts
of the technological social petri dish
that the dead heads were keeping in
business right so if you think about
these inter woven histories already
you've got the dead kind of at the
center of all of these people who are
really innovating in cyber culture and
it's not just the band it's the fans
right the fans using computers the fans
who are making computing who are
building these systems from the ground
up figuring out things that are then
turning on the dead who are going wow
that's exciting let's get more involved
with that also around this time
well actually later you have America
online the Internet and the AOL and
CompuServe and prodigy had not yet
become interconnected it took until 1994
that that gateway opened up so if you
were a person who did not work in the
military or in the government or at a
university or you were not a university
student and you wanted to use the
internet you had to buy a home
subscription to something like America
Online America online like Usenet had a
big system of folders where there were
fan groups discussing whatever it was
that they were fans of including of
course a lot of music groups so when we
get to the World Wide Web
all that was textual internet right oh
that's before we even had a visual Huey
GUI HTML based internet when we get to
so before before we get to the web you
know prints calls up a BBS but that's
about it for like being super innovative
for musicians releasing audiences
reaching audiences where 94 fans totally
got the domain conquered to use a
militaristic metaphor um and of course
the web gets famous for 1999 Napster
shows up
and undermines the distribution models
shall we say of the music industry
Ian Condry did a really nice piece about
the circulation of Japanese hip-hop
where he argues that in fan culture if
you have music you like and you don't
share it you're being immoral right
you're you're you're violating the norms
of the community I heard a really great
song but I'm not going to you know I'm
not gonna play it for you yeah that's a
really bad human who wouldn't play a
really good song for you that they liked
so in that sense Napster it's a
technological innovation obviously one
created by audiences and it was one that
tapped into the morality that already
existed within audience communities it
blew it wide open in a way that it
couldn't have before but it was a
morality that was already there it was
directly the tape trading tree made
instant massive democratizing the tape
tree by 2004 it's the Pirate Bay the
wayback machine is so great if you don't
know about the wayback machine so much
of the old Internet is there what was
happening to our friends REM well REM
hadn't gotten around to building a
website but the 16 year old guy named
Ethan Kaplan he had he made murmurs calm
which was judged cool by Yahoo REM
didn't have a site yet and what I want
to point out about this site yes what I
want to point out about this site in
contrast to that Bowie site or princes
is you can join the REM discussion it's
on the web baby right so the fan sites
that we're getting built we're providing
forums for fans to hang out with each
other to talk to each other to be there
for each other every day
sharing mundane daily activities
continuously over time ever accessible
the interesting follow-up to this is
that at some point our EMS record label
Warner Brothers notice that
site was way better than the official
REM site and so they hired Ethan Kaplan
who was no longer 16 by then and put him
in charge of web presence for all of
Warner Brothers music so once again
you've got the fans boom I'm now in the
middle of industry telling ya how it's
gonna work
he's still really tight with them this
was a example of one of the things that
fans did a tremendous amount of on the
Internet which was building information
repositories I got into this Norwegian
band called madrugada who had a lot of
bootlegs circulating out there on the
Pirate Bay and whatnot which they didn't
mind because they were influenced by the
dead in that regard though not musically
this is one page from that where they
went through and they had done a concert
chronology of every single concert they
had ever replayed the setlist if there
was a record of it whether there was an
own recording of it and if so what
quality that recording was that was
super helpful because I actually found
recordings of every single concert and
to be recorded and I have a really good
mod you got a bootleg collection fans
built archives this is an archive this
is all stuff from the late 2000s this is
an archive of Swedish independent bands
every single one of these is a different
band that this guys put together and if
you click on any one of them you get a
biography of them and links to any mp3s
that might be available out there on the
internet so I asked this guy I said do
you ever feel like you're you know like
doing a lot of work that maybe y'all get
paid for are you kidding the artists are
the ones doing the work I'm just a fan
you've got wick wiki's getting written
all over the internet where fans are
creating the biographies for all of
these artists and now of course if you
go and you go to any search engine and
you put in a band's name the first thing
you'll get if not their official pages
though is the wiki page which is going
to be authored probably by fans
you had mp3 blogs so these are both
examples of blogs one based in Chicago
one based in Paris both of which were
Indus
indie music and we're serving basically
as cultural ambassadors shipping this
stuff out of Sweden to international
audiences with daily updates of songs
that you might like you had things like
it's a trap which was a scandinavian
music news site which was became the new
site that everybody in scandinavia used
to keep up with music if they were into
music including the people in the music
industry and the musicians this was run
by a computer systems engineer who works
from home in Olympia Washington and you
can see that I've actually contributed
the mp3 of it the day in this particular
screenshot I had forgotten about that
tells like wait I wrote that so all of
those are examples of fans collecting
information making information available
collating information serving as
librarians basically information that
artists were often not providing fans
also do a tremendous amount of
interpreting this is just an example of
the lyrics website where you can go and
see what people think any particular
song means fans did a lot of creative
practices on the web stand art of
various kinds this is a silly little
piece of fan art about friends Ferdinand
the band fans write fiction of course
and can share that with each other they
perform their own versions of songs and
they perform their own songs they make
their own music video sometimes the
music videos fans make are more popular
than the ones that the artists make as I
mentioned turbo [ __ ] are very reverent
so what I want you to take from from the
things that I've talked about this far I
want you to take that it's not just that
the internet empowered audiences
although it did that it's that all those
things that audiences got through the
internet they built the audiences made
those things it's not like people sat
there and provided them to them they
created them so the ability to speak the
ability to participate to organize into
groups the infrastructures that were
built for groups the ability to
distribute materials to one another to
create
new materials and share them with one
another to take existing materials and
rework them all of those were things
that the fans on the internet and not
just music fans but fans and general
audiences in general actually created
and I don't mean to say that every
single systems engineer who ever sat
down or every any single internet
architecture ever sat down and did it
was like how can we serve music fans but
what I do mean to suggest is that
amongst all of those people there were a
lot of music fans and they were building
things that were going to work for them
and there were people who were looking
at things that they were on going huh it
sure looks like a lot of people are
doing this kind of thing maybe we better
create a way for them to do that kind of
thing on the thing we're building now
all right so that influence extended far
beyond so in closing I want to give you
a couple of examples of early innovators
of musicians who I think ought to be the
ones who we Harold I you know Bowie and
Prince it's kind of hard to argue with
Bowie and Prince they kind of earned
their stripes but there are some other
people who I think actually ought to get
a lot more attention than they do and
the reason is that these are people who
for one thing are still doing it in the
same way there's a there's a line of
continuity and what they're doing is
they're following the fans and they're
doing they're they're saying who the
fans are doing this how can we help the
fans do this in ways that also allow us
to have sustainable careers so my first
favorite example of this was famous my
first less famous but more innovative
and early innovator is the band
marillion depicted here in a beautiful
piece of fan art so Mark Kelly the
keyboard player for this British froggy
band is backstage in 1991 and some guide
much like the Barlow story some guy
comes up to him with a pile of papers
and says it's a printout from the
marillion fan mailing list and Mark
Kelly's like whoa I had no idea so he
goes home and he writes up his modem and
he logs on to the mailing list and he
lurks on the mailing list for like two
years he just reads it and he never outs
himself and then as he said
and then somebody said something that
was just so wrong I had to tell him I
was there and as soon as he told me was
there this is about 1993 or so as soon
as these outs himself they say how come
you never tour North America because if
think about the demographics of the
Internet at that time it was
predominantly North American although
there were people in England and and
Europe and other parts of the world some
Iranian British band had never toured
North America and suddenly they've got
this fanless full of North Americans
predominantly North Americans wanted to
know why they don't ever tour so Mark
Kelly says well you know first a tour
North America the record label would
have to put up $40,000 and the record
label is not going to put up $40,000
they don't think we have an audience in
America and the fans say well how about
if we raise the money this is remember
1994 and he says well you know I mean
we're not going to touch the money but
if you guys want to gather it sure we'll
tour whatever a few months later they
had raised $60,000 and Mark Kelly had to
tell the rest of the band that he had
promised they were going to tour America
and in 1996 they did to her America on
this fan funded tour and all those
people who had put up equity also bought
tickets right so that was on top of
getting a ticket and what they found
when they went from town to town
was that every town newspaper wrote a
story about this wacky thing that had
happened where the audience paid to fund
the concert so they kind of discovered
as he told me the power of the Internet
and how rabid fans can change things and
make things happen and they continued to
work that so some time later they
realized that they'd sort of did the
math on their record label contract with
EMI and they realized that they would
have to make an album a year to break
even or to you know sustain their
current lifestyle and they were never
gonna be marketed to a larger audience
so they were kind of on a treadmill but
they couldn't really get out of so mark
says hey remember that time that the
audience said they would fund our tour
maybe they'd fund our album and
they had a pre-purchase with a raffle
that they used to pay for the album and
it was really really successful and so
they kept doing it this is from a
screenshot from 2003 where they album 13
we intend to take the established idea
fan power and blow it through the sky
read all about the ideas and plans for
Maroons new upcoming studio album and if
you click that link there's a very long
discussion about the lack of marketing
input from the label and how the
audience or the best marketers and how
we really need you to do this and on and
on and on so this worked pretty well for
a while and then they were like oh you
know what we have enough money we can
put out the next album ourselves we
shouldn't go ask the audience for money
when we can afford to do it that's tacky
that's like you borrow $20 from a friend
and then you go back the next week and
you go hey can I have another $20 about
20 more Connect 20 more dollars so they
decided not to fan fund the album and
what happened was that the audience was
really pissed off
because they felt they'd been cut out of
the process and all those previous
albums the band had been accountable to
them they had to tell him how it was
going they had to bring him in and let
them participate in the process and as a
result they didn't like the album as
much and they didn't engage with it as
much and they went back to fan funding
afterwards not because they needed the
money but because the audience needed
the engagement and they had come to
expect that in their relationship and to
this day they remain fan funded and may
occasionally tour North America
sometimes even playing Boston okay and
then my final example is Kristen Hirsch
and throwing muses more fabulous fan art
so this is somebody who really really
really values the connection with the
audience for whom being on stage and
feeling that moment of connection is
everything it's for lack of a better
word my religion is how she talks about
it she was signed to a major label they
did pretty well if you were around in
the 80s you remember
growing news is being on the radio and
being sort of college radio darlings
they were on cool labels in both the UK
and the US but she felt really cut off
from her audience so the question kind
of became where are they how can I find
them again we'd go to we I'm speaking as
her now we'd go do to record signings
and it was the only time I ever got to
actually see them and all the rest of
time people are rushing me offstage and
taking me away from them and I needed
that right they were the circuit that
made it all whole and they found them in
AO L in a folder where the fans were
hanging out were you there were you on
AOL yeah
and the fan group was called throwing
music good play on throwing muses so
what happened at that point was that
their manager said I think I found them
here they are and he joins the group and
he becomes part of it and he does it
very respectfully right you guys are
here what do you want to know how can I
help let's get to know each other this
is awesome
and he was a fairly visionary character
in many ways and one of the things that
he saw really early was that being on
AOL was a problem because AOL might not
last forever and if their fans were on
AOL that might all turn out to be a
problem and what they did which I think
was just incredibly visionary is that
they talked with the people in this
group about this problem and said okay
we want to make our own site so that you
know we can make sure that you're
sustained and everyone's like yeah
that's cool I don't know maybe a few
people argue but they went over and they
called it throwing music calm so they
actually took the name of the fan group
as the official site this is a
screenshot from 96 this the page
actually began in 94 you could do direct
ordering of music if you are looking for
information or about throwing music
Kristin Hirsch you come to the right
place it's your official online source
for news information and multimedia
materials and you could register and get
all the stuff but what you could also do
if you scroll down and I think this is
what's especially interesting
is you could chat with other throwing
muses and Kristen Hirsch fans in the
real-time chat room alright so from the
very start here you have an artist going
oh you guys are talking if you're coming
with us you got to keep having your
conversation that's part of the deal a
few years later and we're still in the
90s here this is what the site looked
like this is a screenshot from 98 1998
and here what I want to mention is this
this link called the place and if you
clicked on the place you got over here
our own little online community for fans
where you can make your own homepage
exchange messages with other fans and
more so you had basically MySpace for
Kristen Hirsch fans for years before you
had my space and then myspace comes
along right and if we think about well
what was MySpace why did MySpace take
off the way it did it was not the first
social network there had been other
social networks before myspace
BlackPlanet there were there were quite
a few of them but MySpace really really
took off and it's highly likely that one
of the reasons it did is that it very
strategically seeded itself with
musicians in Los Angeles which is where
it was faced so it hooked into that
musician audience relationship and said
people are looking for music people want
to know when the gigs are people are
putting fliers all around town whatever
got everybody doing that on my snakes
and it worked really well and ever and
when you talk to musicians who had
audiences before MySpace and who lived
through this transition they will tell
you all of a sudden people started
contacting us we've never heard from
anybody before and suddenly we were
constantly hearing from fans they they
people who would never have written us
an email didn't think anything about
sending us a message through MySpace
so the floodgates really really open and
this direct this expectation is really
there so when social media
and if you think about it from the fans
perspective there's already an
expectation of connectivity of voice of
productivity and when the musicians now
show up in their life I'm going to
create a page and we're going to be
friends
they're just hooking into what's already
been going on they're hooking into fan
culture rather than fans hooking into
celebrity culture I don't have a lot of
time but just really briefly I before
opening up to questions I want to this
is a whole chapter in its own right and
so I'm just gonna really quickly say
that social media platforms do change
the dynamics a lot because of the ways
that they foster this kind of direct
interaction they also have ultimately I
think proved quite damaging to a lot of
those fan communities that relied on fan
labor to maintain a website because
people just don't go to websites the way
they use stur for those forums there are
still many that are quite successful but
social media platforms really change who
has access if you had to buy a ticket to
a show you don't have to buy a ticket to
go to their web page and tell them how
much they suck for example there is this
expectation of any any time of day right
I'm I'm David Bowie and I'm making
breakfast and I can log on to Twitter
and tweet with my fans if I want right
they're always they're there in your
domestic spaces ever-present ever
available for interaction the power
balances shift dramatically so that it
happens a lot where somebody who might
be a popular musician is not a
particularly popular person on social
media so suddenly they're being followed
by somebody who's got way more followers
than they do and that's actually the
super influential person rather than the
artist in that context and even within
fan cultures sometimes fans will be
extremely influential not necessarily
more so than the artists but enough so
that if they're doing things over there
that might be where the fans want to
hang out rather than over here with a
where the artist is there's also a lot
of ways in which
the behaviors that are have become
acceptable between audiences and
musicians have evolved because of a lack
of clear norms about what do we do in
this environment where suddenly the
artist seems kind of like one of us
right which remember where music starts
of course the artist is one of us
that's the whole point of music is that
we're all us right and in many ways for
many of the artists I've talked with
this is really great
this is really validating because this
means that they can get off that rock
and roll high horse that they never
identified with anyway and just get back
with their people who dig their music
and make life together which was the
point for other people it's really
problematic and one way in which it's
really problematic is that people people
behave very hostile II people behave
very abusively
but also people behave very entitled ly
so that even if they're not being mean
to you they might just want too much
from you
right so musicians tell me about people
who you know they're there every single
thing they do they write they contact
them on every single medium and they're
constantly feeling like this person is
on them and they feel obligated to reply
and they and they feel obligated to
reply sometimes just because they want
to be nice just because they don't want
to be a jerk who says no to somebody who
likes them and appreciates them so that
gets back to that kind of emotional
demand for intimacy and for Monday and
everyday connection that that is called
for so much now and the way that these
media take what's really in a lot of
ways always been there and I hope you've
kind of picked up on that through this
and in a lot of ways that kind of
engagements always been there but it now
the audiences built this way where it
can be there all day every day just like
that and the artists kind of have to
confront that kind of sociality in a way
that they used to be really really
separated from and the end result of
that is that you've got sort of two
really fundamental tensions that play
out in this effort to reach
audiences and to play to the crowd one
of which is on the one hand you want to
control your stuff right Prince was an
exemplar of that desire for control I
want to make sure that my intellectual
property is only used in ways that I
have authorized my favorite bad print
story is when his lawyers were suing a
group of three fan boards and among the
things that they were suing them for was
posting unauthorized its images of
prints that included photographs of
people's tattoos where they'd had his
face tattooed on their own body and he
was claiming those were unauthorized
images that's control right
in fairness Prince was also known like I
said for dialing into bulletin boards
for hosting parties that his house where
all the fans could come in and dance to
his new album I mean he was he was he
loved his fans and he was there for him
but it was also very tight about control
and on the other hand you have this
yearning for participation where you end
up with oh I didn't mention the other
part about throwing music wishes that
you could subscribe and if you
subscribed
you got a mp3 a month and that now for
20 20 years that is how she's funded her
career is through fan subscriptions so
when we talk about who kicks who Amanda
Palmer got so much money on Kickstarter
yeah she did and more power to her but
Kristin Hirsch did it like two decades
earlier and has been doing it
consistently ever since so praise where
it's due right and she did it by
fostering participation right by
recognizing the value of participation
and by I would say rather than control I
would say what she has done is more like
stewardship of sort of these people I
have organized around me and I need them
and the world is precarious and
technology companies can't be trusted so
let's make sure that we do this right
together so that we all are getting what
we need so there is an element of
control inevitably but participation is
really in the fore there and then you
have this real tension that I haven't
talked about as much but I could give
another talk
that next week if you're interested
between trying to keep your professional
distance and that desire for those
mundane details of everyday life which
clash in all kinds of interesting and
fun ways that lead people to do things
like talk about golf because it's the
real me but you don't have to actually
learn anything about me so on that note
I will stop and be happy to take
questions do you feel more relaxed now I
used stressed-out
thesis buddies yes ma'am
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um so it's a great question and I'm
gonna thank you I'm gonna cheat and say
what I say in the book which is that my
the reason I talk about the music that I
talk about
which is not entirely all rock and pop
there are some people from some other
genres but and I have to say that I
didn't
EDM actually was the genre where people
seem to be the most different in the
attitudes toward audiences from the
other genres I spoke with but my my take
on this is that this is an interview
based project which means I had to get
people to let me interview them and it
turns out to be rather tricky to get
professional musicians who had audiences
since before myspace and still do to let
you interview them and I tried really
hard to interview people from a huge
variety of genres and snowballing didn't
work and I failed to get to a lot of
genres and then as I thought about more
I thought well okay so I could say like
people will often say you asked about
opera and jazz people often asked about
hip-hop
well what about hip-hop things are
really different in hip-hop right and of
course of course in many ways so then
I'd be like well yeah I should really
get into hip-hop right I should say I
should make sure I talk to some you
about people but then and you'll
appreciate this I'd be like what about
Brazil well they've got all kinds of
super interesting music cultures why
don't I talk about that and then it
would be like k-pop k-pop Scott all
kinds of stuff going on and so then I'm
like well where do I draw lines
and when I can't talk about everybody
and I decided what I'm going to do is
I'm going to tell the story I know
really really well and I'm gonna hope
that people like you who know those
communities will go this is really
interesting but it's not quite like that
in Opera I'm gonna write about what it's
like in Opera right so what I'm trying
to do is just kind of offer a tale that
people can take elsewhere I do think
that a lot of the things that fans do
are really consistent across different
kinda like those kinds of genres like
making sure that you've got the complete
collection making sure you've got the
first pressings making sure you've got
all the stuff having access to I mean of
course people don't hang out with Maria
Callas anymore but you know if you can
get a selfie with the person that's
really cool or if you at least were
there that's really cool so there are
these ways of competing with one another
and sharing social values and things
that that are the same in their form if
not their content
yeah but certainly rock and pop do too
yeah yeah yeah and I hear people in
classes I'm not necessarily an opera but
I do hear people in classical saying
there's more and more pressure for like
first violinists to have a web presence
so go figure they're you know I wouldn't
have thought that but you are starting
to see you're starting to see that in
genres that haven't always privileged it
it feels like I mean just to talk about
like that
not just have opted like
african-american engagement with social
media precursor to going to many folks
engagement
it's hard to dress yeah I mean I think
that's a fair criticism and it's a
criticism yeah that's I mean I think
that's totally fair and in the book I I
tried to address this by saying you know
I'm telling this one story and I think
the line that I use is please interpret
its absences as invitations because I
there there that's a fact there's no
question about it the book is 80,000
words it could have been 160 thousand
words and I could have gone into hip hop
and I could have gone into all those
things and I could have gone in all
those directions and that's all true I
there are parts of tales that I do tell
in the book that I think are not in this
talk that speak to some of that but yeah
it's true I'm not telling a story about
black music cultures in the United
States I also feel like if I got up here
that's absolutely no yeah you're right
and I and I don't mean to say no you're
right and I do I mean that's that point
is in there and it's a fair criticism
and I tried really hard to talk to a lot
of people who were involved in a lot of
those scenes and nobody wrote me I was
you know and so you know it's I tried
that's all I can really say as I tried
and having failed I thought it was a
little facetious to then go
well I'll just go read a bunch of stuff
and write about it like I'm part of that
scene and I know it really well and to
me that felt as weird you know to talk
about the ethics of dealing with with
with with multicultural multiple
histories and trying to weave it into
one story I felt like ultimately it was
a little disingenuous for me
to claim expertise and stuff that I know
other people know so so well rather than
telling a story that I could tell really
well and hoping that it might encourage
some of those people to say you totally
missed this and that's you know in babes
book she completely ignores this here's
my book to fill that gap and I want
those books I want that whole collection
of gaps because I would have loved to
have been able to follow these things
through so they're not there because I
don't acknowledge them because I don't
know they were they're there because
they're not there because I didn't know
how to get to them in a way that could
do them justice rather than treating
them as okay well I'm totally white but
I'm in pain a little dark around the
corner so that it looks multicultural
which seems insulting to me so it was
hard and I talked to a lot of people
about I talked to race scholars about
how do I do this in a way that can
simultaneously acknowledge that it does
come out of my history in this chapter
in the way that I tell it is really Auto
ethnographic it's not in the version I
just gave you but in the version I tell
in the book it is and how do I tell it
in a way that that can simultaneously
acknowledge yeah it's really white
that's because all the musicians I know
I know from growing up in Urbana
Illinois in a Midwest in a college town
as a white person in a white scene and
having had tastes that were formed in
there and built the networks in there
and that's just where I landed so it's
really just about telling the story that
I felt I could tell fairly so yes you're
right and I don't disagree there yeah
really striking was obviously predating
the internet there were these
international connections among fans but
I don't know if you saw in the research
that that changed at all I mean the the
fact that you had somebody in Olympia
Washington you know with the CEO
authority on Scandinavian music or you
know the fact that a lot of what I
listed you is not produced in the US you
know and I've been able to find that
because of the internet because of these
fan culture and you know a lot of my
most important friendships are exactly
were forged in these chat rooms on for
musicians web sites so can you talk a
little bit about you know has that that
changed because the Internet
yeah the Internet has especially for
artists who didn't have multinational
label record deals the Internet has
undoubtedly allowed international music
floats that were not there previously so
for example I spoke to a Spanish
musician from Spain who suddenly has is
touring South America and Mexico because
they know he exists which they didn't
before a lot of Western bands touring
Asia who don't sell there but have huge
audiences there so yeah a lot of
cultural flows around not just music I
mean also if you think about the whole
fansubbing of American TV and other
television there's a lot of
international new media flows that that
have happened because of the internet
usually happening first because fans are
distributing it in ways that are perhaps
considered unauthorized and often doing
a lot of work to translate materials and
build the structures and pay for their
maintenance
you know I think you again and when you
have 50 pounds of equipment to keep a
concert no no every Deming company which
is the incarnation concert is live
webcast if you don't want to pay for it
there's a pirate screams they're the
people who are periscoping every concert
and the capers are all live-streaming
overmix learn so there's you know
suddenly you don't have to wait for them
to come to town see them you can
definitely see them better from your own
living room and there's a term for it's
called the catch for and their cuties
that have gathered about this either
through Twitter hashtags or rented by
threads and I participate in this
section I'm looking back in terms of
what I think is gonna emerge from it I
think I think abundance is an issue but
I think that as abundance has become an
issue that that thing that Kerry was
talking about about you know the the
limited edition hand sewn whatever also
becomes more and more important so there
is a desire for scarcity I think what
kind of concerns me a little bit about
all of the abundance is the ways that it
undermines the social currency amongst
fans and I feel very torn about it in
the sense that when you were a Deadhead
in 1978 and you got a tape it was like
yes I worked for this tape right and
when you're dead head now you're like
which of 87 streams should I watch Yeah
right and somebody who just found out
about the dead yesterday can find them
just as easily as you right so the thing
that made you cool in 78 because you've
got that tape now there's nothing
special about it cuz even if you're
periscoping live so are 80 people around
you
right so I kind of worry about what
happens to fan culture in an era of
ubiquity where everybody's got
everything and there's nothing to sort
of work for anymore but I don't I feel
like it's really double sided because on
the one hand it's fantastic that you can
see the dead on your couch right that's
great and I don't think it really means
that when they come to town you wouldn't
go right so I think that it's in much
the way that I don't really think that
online communication has supplanted
face-to-face communication I don't
really think that online music
engagement is going to supplant the
concert experience or the dancing
collectively experience which you know
is totally different from sitting on
your couch you know you can't you can
have a dance party on your couch but you
don't get the pleasure of a dance party
and then the possibilities are endless
[Music]
yes but what I ultimately came away from
this project thinking is that the
category of fan and musician is really
super problematic because I don't know
any musician who isn't a fan and I don't
know I have yet to meet people in the
music industry who aren't fans that's
why they're in the music industry right
it's so and and I have spoken with
musicians who are pretty famous you talk
about geeking out when some one of my
favorite things that I'll see on Twitter
from time to time will be like some
musician I admire says something and
then some musician they admire replies
and then they're like oh my god saw the
finish thought victory this is the best
day of my life right and you see that
all the time if you if you follow
celebrities of any kind you see that
there's this constant being excited by
somebody of whom you're a fan so I think
that we need to think about fan and
artist as sort of fluid categories that
people inhabit at different times of
life and day depending on on what
they're doing relative to the people
around them
rather than a sort of identity
categories that you can never really get
out of I think I mean yeah I think
pretty much everybody in in professional
music was a fan who wanted to get in in
some way and in industry cases like the
Ethan Kaplan case I think are less
common but certainly not unheard of I
mean that's a that's a really striking
case but it's it's it happens all the
time where people will hire their fan to
run their web presence through money or
friendship and love them and things like
that so that happens a lot where they go
you know you're doing this so well why
don't we you just do it for us but the
sort of like we the industry the giant
company will take you and give you this
plummeted Giada's
[Applause]
you